hi i'm derek downey a developer advocate
at google i'm currently working on
developing a banking application that
leverages cloud spanner for its ability
to seamlessly scale without losing
strong external consistency
in my last video i highlighted how
simple it was to get started working
with the spanner emulator running on my
own device to run my basic banking app
that's in development
now i want to connect to a real spanner
instance so it can be used for
development by my
team in this video i will dig deeper
into what a spanner instance is and the
different options available when
creating an instance
[Music]
like all other google cloud products
spanner instances must be created inside
a project
so my spanner instance will be created
in my organization's development project
for spanner an instance refers to an
amount of compute and storage capacity
that you get access to
an instance will have at least three
replicas created depending on which
configuration you choose
this means that spanner provides high
availability by default each instance
can have multiple databases depending on
your needs
for my banking application i will create
a single database for customers and
their transaction
the cost of this instance is determined
by how much compute capacity i provision
how much storage my database uses how
much storage my backups use and finally
how much network bandwidth i use
as i get started on this application the
largest cost will come from the compute
capacity itself
the compute capacity cost is determined
by both the number of nodes and the
configuration that i choose
i should mention that in spanner nodes
is the measurement of how much compute
capacity that is provisioned for my
instance this setting has no bearing on
how many replicas i get i will always
get at least three replicas
since i am just getting started with
this application a full node of compute
capacity is too much
luckily i can go smaller than a single
node by using processing units instead
1000 processing units is the equivalent
compute capacity of a single node in
spanner
and i can provision these in increments
of 100
so i will create my instance with 100
processing units which gives me roughly
one-tenth the compute resources of a
single node at one-tenth the cost
besides sizing the other important
factor for creating a spanner instance
is the configuration
the configuration determines how many
replicas i get and where they are
located
it also determines the type of replicas
that are handled by spanner
and luckily as a developer i don't have
to manage the replicas they are
completely managed by spanner
there are two types of configurations in
spanner regional and multi-regional
for regional configurations i would get
three read write replicas in the region
i choose
read write replicas participate in votes
to commit rights
and these replicas can also be promoted
to leader for high availability a
regional configuration is a good option
if my application will be operating
within a single region
i want to choose a region where my
application is located to reduce request
latency
to achieve higher availability though i
would consider a multi-regional
configuration these configurations
provide read-write replicas in two
regions as well as maintaining a witness
replica in a third region witness
replicas do not contain any data but
they do provide votes for quorum
also witness replicas can never be
promoted to become a leader some
configurations also offer read-only
replicas in additional regions these
replicas contain a full copy of data so
that they can reduce read latencies in
that region
however they can never be promoted as a
leader and read-only replicas don't
participate in voting to commit rights
so they don't impact write latency
performance multi-regional
configurations are a great way to
achieve the highest availability for
your spanner-backed applications
it's important that applications are
effectively deployed in the appropriate
regions to take full advantage of the
configuration
you can get more information on
available spanner configurations from
the link in the description
for my development application i'm going
to create a regional configuration in
u.s central 1.
alright so to create my instance i
provided a size and a configuration
all i need now is to provide the name
and an optional description for the
instance
then i can create it
once the instance is created i will need
to update my application to use it
to connect to spanner i will need the
project id for the project that my
spanner instance is located in i will
also need the instance id
i also need to authenticate my machine
to be able to work with the project
resources i do this using the gcloud
command
now in intellij i will create a new data
source and point my new spanner instance
using the project and instance
information
the url connection string is different
as it no longer points to the emulator
and there it's connected
now i will need to modify the
application code with the project and
instance information
if i run my commands to create the
database it will create the customer
table on the development spanner
instance that i just created
now we have our banking application
using a real spanner instance instead of
the emulator my team can start using it
today
my instance is a regional configuration
with a small amount of compute resources
for our development needs
choosing the right configuration is
important so i've provided additional
resources on spanner configurations in
the video description these resources
can help you decide which configuration
might be the right one for your
application
in our next video i will dig deeper into
what database options exist for spanner
in the meantime please let us know if
you have any questions about spanner
instances costs or configurations
[Music]
you